There's so many women that have gone before me and have taken to the sky.
Do you think there is a need for women in space?
Well, is there a need for men in space?
All these women have been my role models and my inspiration,...
...and I couldn't be here today without them.
Ozlem Tureci is the woman behind a leading COVID-19 vaccine.
Women bring an energy to rap that did not exist before.
And the Grammy goes to Cardi B!
Who knows how many others could've been the first if they'd had the chance to try.
Pattern Beauty is launching.
I'm the first person in my family to start a business.
Let's talk about some glass ceilings being shattered.
Junko Tabei summited heights no woman before her had reached.
We can show girls that anything is possible.
It doesn't matter what they look like or where they come from.
They can change the world.